cuál de las siguientes es una
interpretación correcta de la expresión
16 bueno antes incluso de leer esto solo
pensemos en lo que está pasando en 16 en
la recta numérica empezaré en 1 lo que
será uno a la derecha de cero y luego
sumar es 6 y de 6 más a la derecha de 0
para acabar en 7 lo que será 7 a la
derecha de 0 el número que está seis
unidades a la izquierda de uno en la
recta numérica seis unidades a la
izquierda de uno en este tipo de recta
numérica la cual es una recta numérica
estándar la cual a la derecha es
positiva y a la izquierda es negativa si
mueves 6 a la izquierda eso significa
que está restando 6 de 1 eso no es
correcto estamos sumando 6 el número que
está seis unidades a la derecha de uno
en la recta numérica
eso es correcto vamos 6 a la derecha
está sumando 6 te mueves a la derecha
estás incrementando por lo que esa será
definitivamente nuestra elección
continuemos cuál de las siguientes es
una interpretación correcta de la
expresión 3 más menos 7 incluso antes de
ver estas opciones una manera en la que
pensaría en eso es empezar en 3 y luego
me movería 7 a la izquierda de 3 estoy
sumando menos 7 esto es lo mismo que 37
nuevo 7 a la izquierda de 3 veamos lo
que nos dice empieza en 7 en la recta
numérica y mueve 3 a la izquierda eso no
tiene sentido empezaríamos en 3 salte
monos hasta esta opción empieza el 3 en
la recta numérica y mueve 7 a la
izquierda eso es correcto empezaremos en
3 y nos moveremos 7 en la dirección
negativa
la convención nuestra convención
estándar nos dice que hacia la izquierda
es negativo y hacia la derecha es
positivo eso será correcto hagamos uno
más ahora tenemos tres menos -4 bueno
una manera de pensar en eso es 3 menos 4
negativo es lo mismo restar un negativo
que sumar un positivo es lo mismo que 3
+ 4 y entonces empezaría en 3 y luego me
movería 4 a la derecha porque nuevamente
esto es lo mismo que 343 menos 4
negativo es lo mismo que 3 + 4
empezaremos en 3 y nos moveremos 4 a la
derecha empieza en 3 y muévete 4 a la
derecha esto sería lo mismo que tres más
4 que es lo mismo que esa expresión